hi my name is Kate Hampton I'm executive
director for climate change at the
children's investment fund foundation
we're a philanthropic foundation based
in London and we fund technical
assistance and advocacy campaigns around
the world I'd like to answer a question
from sweaty in Mumbai who made this
question on facebook which is what is
the one thing in 2012 you'd like to see
happen in the world and it relates very
closely to the question lies underneath
from someone that calls themselves a lot
atmosphere on YouTube about how can
there be sustainable growth when
resource depletion is imminent so the
one thing I'd like to see in 2012 is
that heads of state at the g20 and the
real plus 20 summit acknowledge that
green growth isn't something that you
can deal with after you've got back to
business as usual and resolve the
financial crisis that actually green
growth is the only way forward so I'd
really like to see heads of state be
held accountable for bringing us out of
this crisis with a radically change
model for macro economic governance for
policy change for managing environmental
resources and I really like to see young
people pushed push very very hard on
their leaders particularly g20 leaders
to make this reality thanks